as of this moment we have less than two
weeks until a very major Samsung launch
event what's going on guys my name is
David homage and welcome back to the
channel today we're going to be
discussing the brand new Samsung Galaxy
Z flip and the samsung galaxy s xx altra
I'm gonna focus on the ultra more so
because it has all the high-end specs
and all the high-end features that the S
20 and the s 20 plus or pro depends
where they actually named it don't have
so we're gonna be focusing on these two
devices and every single leaked rumor
that's come out so far there's pretty
much guaranteed by this point but let's
start with the samsung galaxy z flip
this is gonna be a revolutionary phone
more in the foldable market again why
it's called the flip Z I don't really
know because it's only gonna be a single
axis flip straight down the middle like
the old-school motor rollers and the new
Motorola they just brought out a couple
months ago it's gonna feature a six
point seven inch full glass display
which is a huge step forward from the
Samsung Galaxy fold which was a plastic
polycarbonate kind of screen finish
which scratched and was super malleable
and was just well garbage pretty much
this new display is going to be full
solid Gorilla Glass which means it's
gonna be a lot more durable for you guys
and it's gonna be able to withstand a
lot more opens and closes because if
you're buying a flip phone that's one of
the main reasons you buy it to just play
with it and flip it all the time even
with this folding technology it comes in
weighing at a hundred and eighty-three
grams to be able to get it down this
much they've actually completely ripped
out the headphone jack from this device
as they have from the new Samsung S 20
range as well so all Galaxy phones
moving forward seems like they're going
to be going without the headphone jack
to a full wireless connection if they
can I'm assuming give it a couple more
years maybe the 2324 model is gonna come
out with no charging points whatsoever a
couple of the specs that we've seen
leaked for the ZD flip is an 855 plus
Snapdragon chip inside so not the latest
86
the fire that's predicted in the new
phones but the 855 plus not too bad it's
still pretty good chip inside eight
gigabytes of RAM and 128 gigabytes of
storage no SD card and no 5g
compatibility so this phone is gonna
kind of be a prehistoric device
internally when you compare it to the
s20 ultra but at the same time it is
still a flagship and it's gonna have the
awesome flip forwarding technology with
the Gorilla Glass so if you take away
some of these hardware things and look
at it as overall phone it's still gonna
be a pretty fantastic device at the end
of the day camera wise we're talking a
three camera setup one in the rear and
the F 1.8 12 megapixel camera just your
standard wide camera lens
the second rear camera is an ultra wide
F 2.2 so not as wide aperture as the
original 1.8 wide but still pretty
decent again 12 megapixels we'll talk
about this 20 Ultra in a minute and you
see why this isn't exactly setting any
trends at the moment but it is still
pretty much your benchmark for most
phones in 2020 but what I can tell for
so far in 2020 most phones are going to
be pushing for that ultra kind of hide
their cell are look in their cameras so
hopefully we're going to be seeing some
much higher specs with all phones coming
out real soon we also have the third
camera which is the front 10 megapixel
camera the only special feature here is
the simple fact that it has auto focus
and auto tracking this hasn't really
happened in the past with any phones
that have been flagship mainstream so it
is a nice little touch what I don't
really understand is the simple fact
that one it's a flipped phone so you can
obviously use the rear cameras as a
selfie camera so was this foreign camera
even needed could have they go on for a
full single display maybe maybe not that
isn't my call to make leave a comment
down below if you think they could have
easily dropped that front-facing camera
because they have those two good cameras
on the back that you can simply close
your phone and take a quick selfie
especially knowing that you have a 366
by a hundred and sixty pixel screen on
the front I think
mentions at the moment that you can view
this selfie on and take a great photo at
the same time obviously being a flip
phone
you can't run a battery through the
whole thing bend at a hundred million
times over and hope for the best
so this time around they've gone with a
3300 milliamp battery so total 3,300
hours which is a relatively decent
battery life you'll get out of most
standard phones I think your Samsung S
20 is probably going to be about that
benchmark whereas the s20 ultra is gonna
be a 5000 so life consistency and life
expectancy of the Zed flip probably not
going to be great but they'll do the job
you'll get a pretty average life
expectancy out of it and most likely it
will last you most of the day at the
moment we've been rumored and told that
it's going to cost about 1650 USD which
comes in over the $2000 Australian mark
that's that's pretty hefty especially
for a flip phone but considering the
fact that the Samsung Galaxy fold came
in at over three thousand Australian
we've dropped a thousand bucks in less
than twelve months so from a technology
point of view and from a consumer point
of view dropping that price tag down so
low so quickly
fantastic work from Samsung ok so moving
on to the Samsung S 20 ultra enough
about the dead flip we've actually been
told that we're going to be getting
three devices from Samsung this time
around we're gonna get the s20 the S 20
plus and the s 20 ultra all expected at
different price points with different
cameras and different features the s 20
is going to come in with a 6.2 inch
display the s 20 pro 6 point 7 and the s
20 ultra 6.9 six point nine inches is
basically the same as what we're getting
on the note plus series at the moment
which is a massive device especially if
you're not used to it
if you're running a standard Samsung S
10 and you move to an s2000 truck this
is a huge huge jump you're gonna be
struggling to type and it's gonna feel
so awkward and so out of place trust me
I've done it plenty of times and for one
of the main things that driving me
especially and I think most of the
consumers out there to upgrade to this
s2000 which is rumored to come in at
1300 USD
or just under 2,000 Australian dollars
is the rear camera setup we're talking
something pretty substantial and a very
huge upgrade and upgrade I'm definitely
looking forward to we're talking 108
megapixels for the rear main camera 48
megapixel is for the rear telephoto
camera with a hundred times digital
optical zoom combination this is a
hybrid of ten times optical zoom
followed by an additional 90 to 100
digital zoom you're gonna be able to
zoom in so far and recognize so many
things that you're gonna be thinking
[ __ ] am I looking at one of these hyper
telephoto ultra 1 million megapixel
photos you see on the internet that you
can zoom right in and see people's faces
from space that's the kind of tech we're
looking at inside your smartphone which
is super awesome to see the only short
side I have with this is the 12
megapixel ultra wide camera on the back
is kind of a bit of a letdown
I'm hoping it's able to keep up with the
quality of the cameras beside it
especially the 108 megapixel bigger
brother because for me personally the
telephoto is one of the main and most
used cameras on the back of my phone
it's something that allows you to
capture the whole room capture space and
really really give you that sense of the
ambience and the vibe of the room so the
telephoto for me is just as important as
the main camera so stepping down from a
hundred and eight million pixels to 12
megapixels a bit of a letdown but that
is okay some things we have to sacrifice
in life and moving forward from a tech
world we know how quickly technology
moves and we know how quickly we're
going to end up with a hundred and eight
main 108 telephoto and a hundred and
eight ultra wide camera on the back of a
flagship device I give it two three
years hardware is all well and good but
the software is super important as well
guys and Samsung's is secretly announced
that two extra bonus camera shooting
modes are going to be added in the
Samsung S 20 lineup so all three the
Samsung S 20 the s 20 Pro and the s 20
ultra will be getting a single take and
quick
take so the theoretically supposed
single take is blackphone open single
take pan your phone around and it will
automatically take photos from all three
cameras and take videos at the same time
stitch it edit it together and make
something cool how useful this is going
to be dunno it might be a super gimmicky
Instagram story one day but otherwise
don't say it's super helpful
however quick take is a feature that is
super cool to me you literally open up
your phone quick take it takes three
photos on all three cameras saves them
to your camera roll and you can decide
later what you want so if you don't have
time to setup compose a shot or you
really just want to take that memory
shot which a lot of us do when we're
going on holiday and we see something
that's not super Instagram bought or in
just don't care but we love the moment
we love the space and we love everything
about it we want to take as many photos
as possible so quick take will
definitely be one of my most used
features on the f2000 ultra in the
upcoming videos coming later February
something that's also interesting to
note is previously we've been told that
will be getting 8k video recording files
on the f2000 truck they've always stated
that we're going to get it at 30 frames
a second and then we'll get 4k at 60
frames a second neither with high
dynamic range capabilities that's okay
not the worst thing in the world you can
film in 1080 with high dynamic range
that's what you want if you're a studio
setup 8k is going to be incredible but
the thing to take note here is all the
developers and all the leak leaks that
have come out have secretly implemented
that 30 frames a second is out and
they're bringing in 24 frames a second
as standard so for all the videography
guys out there and the cinematography
guys 24 frames a second is that buttery
smooth slow-motion b-roll footage that
you see all the time on your favorite
youtubers channels so implementing 24
frames a second is going to make sure
this camera and this phone cells to way
more people way quicker my prediction is
that the s20 ultra will be one of the
highest selling smartphone devices on
the market in 2020 surpassing anything
that the Apple
bringing out this year I think the
iPhone 12 will be an amazing device but
I don't think it's going to be able to
catch up as quickly as what Samsung's
done here in this s2000 ultra last but
not least it's expected to launch at
1,300 us so just under two grand
Australian on the 13th of March will be
the actual physical handover date of the
devices to individuals like yourself and
myself the launch date is scheduled for
the 12th of February here in Australia
which is the 11th of February in San
Francisco where the launch event is
being held it is definitely going to be
something I will be covering so if it is
something that interests you smash that
subscribe button down below and follow
me in a couple of weeks when I go
through the full breakdown of what this
s20 ultra will be and pre-order the
device for myself anyway that's all I
have for you guys today thank you so
much for watching and that was a full
recap of the s20 ultra and the expected
Samsung Galaxy Z flip will flip Zed will
say which one they go with but that's
all I have thank you so much I'll see
you next Monday